>>> In our tech lead Elon Musk
is threatening to sue.
The website formally known as a
Twitter.
He claims that without any
evidence that we have seen it.
The statements about rising
hate speech on the platform of
the reason why there has been a
60% decrease in advertising.
Other organizations have noted
that the increase in the speech
on the platform since Elon Musk
took over.
Removed much of the content
moderation in a spokesman
responded.
We are not surprised yet
undeteinedined that the anti-
semites, white supremacists and
other people have launched an
attack.
This is nothing new.
This is not the first time T
Elon Musk is ready to take
legal action.
The last one was a nonprofit
group that found that hate
speech on X has risen,
dramatically under the new
ownership of Elon Musk.
And thank you for joining us.
And Elon Musk later said quote
to be super clear.
I am a pro free speech but
against anti-semitism of any
kind.
Never really good sign when he
had to clarify to people they
were against anti-semitism.
But it is just true.
This is part of his free speech
position.
When you take this purist free
speech position.
Although it is not real.
He blocks free speech.
But he allows anti-semitism to
flourish.
We've all seen it.
>> The first of opportunity, is
he will say that he is for free
speech.
It is his cloak which is
transparent.
You know, it is threatening to
groups. Many of these academic
groups.
I used to speak to them and
they were very nervous to do
reports.
It has a chilling impact.
Because they are going to be
subject by a lawsuit.
By the world's richest man.
And this is the worst platform.
That is why advertising is
down.
This tactic is paying the dues.
That is what he is doing.
That is why everybody is
incensed about his this.
His tweets are very carefully
calibrated.
And all the times that he will
say that he is not an anti-
semite.
Called him that.
>> Right.
But I've seen some people call
that that.
But you know, he blames the adl
and they do not speak for
jewish people.
>> Neither does he.
>> Right.
>> Nobody does.
>> You know, I am still on X
and other sites.
But it is it not true?
That he regularly engages with
people who are white
supremacists and anti-semites.
That sends a signal to people.
That he is engaging with these
people.
>> It is actually very jocular.
He has allowed people to come
back on who have been thrown
off.
That Twitter had taken off.
Because under their rules and
now he has new rules.
He can allow them right back
on, just like former president
Donald Trump.
He will engage in this manner.
It does not say that could be a
problem.
Like today, the polar opposite
came on his temperament and
style.
Mark Cuban was engaging over
their obsession. I guess the
burning man festival set them
off.
>> The 29-year-old woman.
>> They have someone to attack
every day.
So he was engaging in a really
interesting way.
Debating.
But it was just not
interesting.
That kind of stuff.
It is getting people giving
them signals.
>> So, last month, the new CEO
of X. That Elon Musk hired.
To run the company.
Linda yakareno said that the
brands were coming back to X.
And they were going to break
even.
Did that happen?
Are they profitable?
>> I have no idea.
But the advertising has
increased.
But with the layoffs, he has
insulted advertising. And
threatened them.
It is always somebody's fault.
That is the problem.
And she is very professional.
It has her hands full.
But some of her statements
everything is great here.
There is no problem.
What it is like being told that